una cadena de asesinatos en albuquerque
todos conectados por el origen y la
religión de las víctimas cuatro hombres
musulmanes asesinados en un lapso de 10
meses el martes se dé un gran avance un
sospechoso fue detenido y acusado de dos
de los asesinatos
fiftyone y rolf mohamed sayid /
detuvimos a matsa jet de 51 años y lo
acusamos del asesinato de dos hombres
musulmanes de nuestra comunidad aftab
hussein y mohamad afzal estamos
trabajando con la oficina del fiscal del
distrito sobre posibles cargos por el
asesinato de otros dos hombres
musulmanes naim sahin y mamá armada como
aquí
el primer asesinato tuvo lugar en
noviembre y los tres siguientes en las
últimas dos semanas para la cuarta
muerte ocurrida el viernes la policía
reveló que creía que los casos estaban
relacionados
nuestra ciudad sufrió otra trágica
pérdida durante la noche otro joven que
formaba parte de la comunidad musulmana
fue asesinado hay razones para creer que
esto está relacionado con tiroteos
los cuatro hombres formaban parte de la
diáspora musulmana de 5.000 habitantes
de alburquerque y sus asesinatos a tiros
estilo emboscada mantiene aterrorizada a
toda la comunidad
este es un momento realmente surreal
para nosotros tememos por la seguridad
de nuestros hijos de nuestras familias
no se trata sólo de la comunidad
musulmana sino de toda la comunidad
estamos todos juntos en esto
es narval ya estamos con timidez y
paciencia que me revelaba la llegada se
espera que la detención del sospechoso
contribuya a aliviar esos temores